il s'est excusé aujourd'hui on se trouve
si on médiévale engineers on va
construire des tas de trucs c'est mon
rêve de mettre ce jeu exactement c'est
parti j'ai suivi le tutoriel pas de
panique
normalement non merde ah ben voilà les
touches c'est exactement ça qu'il me
fallait finalement ne tient pas de but
dans ce jeu finalement à part construire
tout et rien et détruire aux citoyens
mais ferme c'est tout ce qu'on aime
récemment sur cette chaîne et d'en faire
ça je peux par exemple construire un
petit cube tetris est monté dessus
monter des projets dits de là je
m'envolais donc tu vas te calmer et je
peux aussi faire une tour
on va faire une tour jusqu'à ou attend
on va atteindre l'espace quoi ça tombe
bien c'est le jeu a été fait par les
mêmes qui ont fait space invaders
on va se retrouver dans l'espace avec
sept tours 1 une tour comme ça ça passe
oui monsieur boîte mais pourquoi est ce
qu'à ce mec mumbai steak je la prends
avec la force de mes mains c'est comme
superman tissu elle en avion avec des
gens dedans moi je sens votre truc quand
je ferai le tour
la légende dit que le prince qui
arrivera on n'y trouvera pas une
princesse mais il trouvera un homme et
cet homme [ __ ] mais déjà si à tour
tient pas debout on peut pas créer une
légende à la fin je peux créer ma
légende la légende raconte que le prince
qui ramène à la fin si je fais contrôler
v on peut copier coller des choses par
exemple je peux la mettre là dire c'est
bien plus stylé d'avoir cette maison
relié à la montagne quoi au nom elle se
paie de nom mais plus ça c'est quoi au
noir saccadé kolingba al'inverse on va
tout raser du coup atteint on peut
compter un truc souterrain mais oui mais
si on fait une passe ou terra nova un
bunker
la légende raconte que l'homme qui
trouvera les galeries souterraines de by
then came trouvera de l'or des femmes
mais avant toute chose des escaliers on
a dit lula page est en train de préparer
la légende d'escalier vue la légende dit
qu'un soir de plaine étoiles ya pas de
lune fait chier un homme trouvera une
grotte secrète entre les fougères et les
mauvaises herbes
c'est quelque chose de très beau il
aurait intérêt tentateur sinon ya tout
qui va cramer va [ __ ] tout la légende
de cons est que plus loin dans cette
petite grotte il tombera sur des
escaliers escalier qui le mèneront
peut-être vers la voie lactée
peut-être bien [ __ ] mais un escalier
qui veulent surtout [ __ ] de bordel
qu'est ce que c'est que ça aurait
personne ne croit à cette légende est
mort aussi les soins au coeur des
légendes pour la légende dit qu'il devra
voler sur 2 m ou sauter aussi continuer
et puis une fois sur les marges au
dessus cet homme devra soudainement
sauté dans le vide
[ __ ] [ __ ] mais n'ont pu terminer à
tous qu'ils plantent dans cette [ __ ]
de légende de merde devrait s'accroupir
et sauter dans le vide
ça me fait un effort à la fin j'en peux
plus devra sauter dans le vide par le
côté bordel de merde
ah voilà et en faisant voler de ses
propres ailes jusqu'à la sortie et
trouvera d'un coup une chaise au cette
légende et nuls mais nulle moi le vrai
c'est qu'on soit un vrai truc c'est
parti on la musique hippiques la voie là
puisqu'il ya des torches
oui sa torche murale c'est parfait
attention regardez regardez ça prend
forme mais ça prend vie ou pas ou pour
moi je le vois juste là commençait à
prendre vie tac
là on rajoute le petit et là attention
d'appui sûreté ça tourne ça tourne
d'ailleurs je vous réserve une petite
surprise puisque je les fais pile en
face de cette maison là bas attache la
corde donc là logiquement si on fait ça
oh non je dois toujours faire si ça
tourne dans le mauvais sens bon du coup
j'ai fait une double catapulte voilà tu
t'en sors bien pour cette fois maison
donc là normalement en toute normalité
son habit sûreté ça ramène bon ça va
marcher je comprends pas pourquoi
j'appuie sûreté que je mette à côté de
l'autre ça ne marche pas fuck it
j'entends la maison rigoler ce que tu
rigole quand je te mets déboule comme ça
qu'on l'appelle je fais une poutre en
bois non non j'étais en train de faire
un truc drôle messieurs dames si jamais
certains trouveront la gymnastique
maintenant l'épreuve de poutres se
passera à 50 mètres du sol d'accord et
votre chien instituteur appuiera sûreté
et la poutre tournera et vous avez
intérêt à aller jusqu'au bout de cette
poudre si vous y allez pas si le coup de
fouet voilà j'ai fini ma vanne
maintenant on va tester les choses
workshop aussi désastreux pour moi là
j'étais chargé des petits trucs des
petites mains par exemple la map
spaceship voilà où on est sur scène et
dans l'espace
encore mal se passer comme à chaque fois
depuis 2007 vu que t'étais où on y est
alors [ __ ] c'est quoi avec
attendez si j'appuie sur t il se passe
quoi ça a tourné un peu bon jour il ne
se passe absolument rien
l'adp apparemment de mec à fabriquer une
araignée alors allez oust râteau est ce
que c'est ça drake a fabriqué sa qu'il
voulait faire quoi lasser pour tout y
est les eaux qu'enfin gâteau aux [ __ ]
regarder ce que je viens de construire
et que ça fait deux heures que je suis
dessus j'ai construit un tank
merci le workshop de steam attend le mec
ça ce pilote vraiment nous sommes de
retour sur le space il je ne comprends
pas pourquoi absolument tout ce que je
fais ne marche pas qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire je comprends pas faut détacher sa
voix là en bas comment est ce tu as as
assez détaché en hausse à 1,3 me mais
non mais ces foires et regardez le leur
soit complètement raté mais regardez
quoi la passerelle tout et tout et en
l'air des millions de francs comme sa
partie en l'air oh c'est parti ce que je
peux pas du tout oui là je ne comprends
pas pourquoi mac à tabac des je refais
une catapulte attention voyons voir si
le levier marche
je suis l'homme le plus heureux du monde
croît de plus qu'avec la petite duo la
ola elle est contente pas de regarder la
bo allez allez maintenant pourquoi
attendaient déjà ça c'est beaucoup trop
voilà c'est plus exactement de cette
heure d'été beaucoup trop tendue elle
aussi tendu coin dans cette vidéo je
vois pas du tout la normande ne plus
avoir attendez on voit que dans la rue
je veux que tout le monde voit ce que je
suis en train de faire quand je dis tout
le monde c'est tout le monde mon gars
est une [ __ ] de c'est quoi la secte de
la catapulte tu vas tenir seul au prix
de boules
oui ne meurent pas l'avoir ya pas si
lumière il faut mais des lumières
partout dans une spirale ak-47 et non je
croisais lampe tintin tintin tintin on
n'a rien vu on n'a rien vu c'était nul à
chier
on attendait tous ce grand mouvement qui
a patience étaient tous pourris
oh oh oh le mec qui a faim labyrinthe de
doc et toi c'est l'entrée messieurs
dames nous allons c'est nous en sortir
labyrinthe le remake avec squeeze dans
le rôle de l'homme qui meurent au bout
d'une minute
en fait on voit là il ya juste aller
tout droit comme ça ah oui bloquer
dikalo mange du ca ont il a mis un petit
peu d'herbe si mignon ou celui là
vraiment pris soin de nous a lancé son
bichon en se rapprochant on s'approche
de la vérité un bâtonnet on va y arriver
sur déconner je mets pas tes j'ai je
vous promets que je n'ai pas triché et
ce même pour une fois de la succion
crois que c'est de l'ironie veut même
pas c'est juste à la sortie on y est
emmerdes
oh non non mais c'est les russes est
juste là il sortira que le mur il fait
en béton près on peut n'avoir vous ansa
c'est comme ça comme ça c'est comme ça
je vais bien ou pas non en emmenant mais
l'osmose aussi beaucoup ont eu quelque
chose de réussi dans cette vidéo web on
va la jouer à fond de cette vidéo sur
mes d'evolène geignant ce [ __ ] ce que
j'ai été mauvais pourtant j'ai fait
l'effort de regarder la vidéo tuto de 15
minutes avant de faire cette vidéo mais
ça n'a pas suffi je ne comprends pas par
exemple pour la pro à catapulte que j'ai
fait quand j'ai activé la manivelle la
corde ne ramenez pas là la catapulte je
comprends pas rien de marché tout le
temps c'est incroyable n'hésitait pas à
mais la vidéo comme ça vous a plu si
vous avez ch'ti siens 1-1 ou si vous
zappez chier c'est aimer la vidéo si
vous êtes fait chier leur amour c'est
comme comment alors plus de pouce vert
que d'habitude en tout cas mr savoir
regarder la vidéo on se construit
attendant une prochaine note monde
puisses tu attends je prends du plaisir
à faire sans boiter de plus que l'on
paie pas d'accord